it is our last hour of a too short
two-day stint here in New York City and
please to finish things up with one of
our friends of the program since we've
been on the air we turned five in
October and power turned six and it's
the final season of power Sundays at
8:00 Eastern and Pacific on Starz
welcome Brooklyn's Finest Geri Ferraro
to the program good to see you buddy
that felt good Brooklyn's file like you
are man I'm just that now I was born in
Brooklyn that's and then and then to
date myself a little bit the Verrazano
Bridge got built
my parents are New York City public
school educators and they there are many
of the New York City employees who went
across the bridge from Brooklyn to
Staten Island yeah my mom's out in
Staten Island is that right yeah she's
on Staten Island my brother and I went
to college for I did a brief stint at
CSI yes did so funny everyone sees CSI
you see me think it's crime scene
investigation oh I grew up it's the
College of Staten ah that's right they
should do a show about a crime scene si
si si si si si si gone full matter right
there yeah that's right where where
David Caruso just says forget about it
you know all right I'm I'm done with
that life ah good to see you man it's
good to see ya um
Yanks how fired up are you right now
what what do you got cuz we just did
Mets I guess we're gonna be fair and
balanced right here we just had Polly
Pete Alonso no I'm um I'm extremely
fired up because it feels real and it
hasn't felt this real and in a long time
in this point me I don't wanna it's hard
to get really upset with the Yankees cuz
they've given me so much but you know
the last few years have been tough and
what I like about this year is you know
we've had some losing streaks the way we
bounced back from that disaster in
Boston really showed me what this team
was Abunda Yankees went and they played
that four-game set yeah Boston that I
think started in late July yeah it was
yeah started in late July and Tanaka
gave up 15 home runs in the first inning
literally the first inning and they won
like 19 million to - mm-hmm
and um and a buddy of mine who I went to
grade school with text me he goes is
this the Boston Massacre in Reverse
and I'm like what's just pump the brakes
low a little bit here
and and just it really is all about
what's going to happen in October now
right really like if the Dodgers the
Yankees the Astros and in a little bit
of the Braves if they could snap their
fingers and start October right now what
you'll be free would which would be yeah
now this would be a perfect time I mean
obviously I start to get worried because
everything in the playoffs obviously
shrinks and you really you're seeing a
number one or two starter every two
games it feels like so it or everyday
everyday essentially are you are you one
of those Yankees fans that are they're
genuinely concerned that this all goes
down the tubes in Houston no I'm not
because like I said it feels a little
more real this year I think every time
that the backs have been sort of against
the wall cuz we've been such a front
running team this year right they've
always pushed back and so I feel like if
we you know matched up with Houston
again I think we'll punch back and and
be ok it would be helpful if the 7th
game would take place if it does it
takes place in the Bronx as opposed to
Houston great right now the Yanks have
only a half game lead over over the
Astros nada
they had a bigger lead but the sweep in
Oakland really hurt them and the ABS are
coming into town later on this weekend
in the Bronx and then again just Houston
it's got such great pitching man I know
and great pitching and those
right-handers that the Yankees usually
have issues with in the playoffs that's
that's the guys that they put on the
mound pretty much I also don't enjoy
although you would think I would enjoy
for some reason on social media I get a
lot of like this dude looks like Jose
Altuve comparison I think it's maybe the
height situation too and look I love al
Chile's a fantastic player I'm honored
but when you if you lose to the Astros
and then you see that it hurts a little
more it's a little more of a dig than an
honoring can I make you feel better
sure okay at least you're running style
isn't compared to Daren revellers on I
get that like every day where he's
running like uh like he's a box of
straws that just dropped on the ground
and and they they think that I run like
that or people like hey let's see them
in a race I'd rather I would rather be
there you go right there we put it up
there for
our loss a man of others I would rather
be compared to Jose Altuve just hurts
when you know if the Yanks drop one to
the Astros and then you see that it's
like uh because imagine if that guy was
on the Yankees this would be the best
comparison that ever happened should be
the best thing that ever happened well
usually back when we were younger you
just wait three years and they'll join
right exactly we'll get him at some
point he's coming I know that's what you
know I wouldn't say that - Pete Alonzo
he seems like such a sweet guy and
everything's working so well for the
Mets just wait till the will ponds don't
pay him we'll see him in pinstripes
you know I mean that wrong was that
wrong to say just after hanging up from
sweet Pete Alonzo just like that no
thanks to the Mets for having him
calling of the show
certainly when he's just tearing the
cover off the ball as well Jerry Ferrara
here on the Rich Eisen show are you
ready to go to the Pro Football Hall of
Fame in Canton Ohio and see Daniel Jones
in there after his first three preseason
games Jerry do you want to go and visit
his body I booked my plane tickets for
18 years from now I'm gonna take my son
coz 18 okay very good and we'll go to
the pro we'll be at his induction at his
speech and I'm trying no he's already
did I know if you missed it yes again
you just mentioned you have a newborn
things you know your baby awful oh but
yeah he's already in the he's already in
the Pro Football Hall of Fame look
there's nothing better than overreacting
or under reacting to preseason because I
could go you can go either way
um I defended the pick as best I could
because I do agree with some that the
pick came in a really interesting place
but uh look I'm I am just hopefully
optimistic cuz again the Giants have
also given me a lot not as much as the
Yankees right I'm still riding off of oh
seven and 11 but it's bits it's been a
minute it's it's time to get back to at
least some playoff football in New York
I need it you're talking about the two
years that I believe has earned Eli the
right to start this season and see how
the season goes unless it's a total
complete unmitigated Owen for oh and
five disaster which we have
unfortunately seen right develop
recently for the Giants he's gonna start
there's no way you take Daniel Jones out
of the box and throw him out there week
one in Dallas no matter how great he's
looked in the preseason no matter how
great he might be look
in training camp and in practices as
well right now this is Eli's gig right
now to take as far as he can look I
agree with that I do agree and look that
that's that's a blueprint that I don't
want to happen meaning like I don't want
them to go oh in five and and and all
that I do think Eli deserves one more
shot we've got a great running back
hopefully the offensive lines sort of
figures that I'm a little concerned
about the wide receiver depth that's
been going on with the injuries and
stuff like that but look if they are on
five you could you could start to slowly
you know inject Daniel Jones into the
lineup I think you're gonna miss out
I don't either look I don't want to be
the the hopelessly optimistic fan but um
I got good feelings about that yeah I'm
looking for ever gonna get simplified
run the ball hopefully we get some
opportunistic plays out of Eli and
hopefully get some time I just want to
see him a little more time I get that
the arm strength was a little up up and
down last year I want to see him with
more than a second and a half the pro
there's no question Daniel Jones's
better arm strength I mean let's be
honest one guy's pushing 40 one kid one
guy just came off the campus of a
college so that but neck up neck up
knowing the defense's before they before
they maybe appear in front of you seeing
what the defenses are doing before you
snap the ball knowing where the
receivers need to be knowing where the
defense might shift based on where
you're sending your receivers that's Eli
head and shoulders I mean you can't even
III and I know how smart guys from Duke
might be but that that's all that needs
to be played out and last night at the
NFL 100 event that I'm in town for
Brockman and I saw along with Mike last
night sacrum Barclays yeah I mean there
guy he is I mean we just heard how great
Pete Alonzo his sweet guys dream come
true sacrum Barkley is too good to be
true and he said to me last night that
he's been a little bit upset of the lack
of snaps that he's gotten in preseason
that's good since he can't wait like he
wants to go and they're there this is a
caged lion exactly I love it this is
this is one of those bucking horses
in the stall getting ready to go win a
Triple Crown right now I I think you
know doesn't matter seven eight man
France I think he's gonna be spectacular
spectacular and people are thinking well
Giants let's count him out
III really am looking for I'm not just
saying it because you're sitting here
no and look if Eli's shown us anything
and maybe this is the hopelessly
optimistic fan is he's probably at his
best when he is counted out now he has
been counted out for a year or two and
we're waiting for the best to come back
but um yeah this is this is and you
really do want to try to win as many
games while you have se Quan just
chomping at the bit to get out there and
bring everybody over so uh I I'm excited
I mean there's been a void in my life I
I couldn't figure out what it was I'm
walking around like why do I feel like
something's missing and it's just okay
we're at the part of summer where we
need football this year and basketball
to come back this year we're here well
speaking of which Jerry Ferrara here on
the Rich Eisen showed you have a four
month old boy right I do
Xion Ferrara is that his name by the way
I don't this is gonna sound like a joke
but it's not I lobbied extremely hard
yes it was maybe about three or four
nights before the draft and I'm like we
could still cuz he was born before not
like we could still switch this and my
wife wasn't having it but I really would
if the Knicks would have drafted Zion I
wouldn't I would have thought was a
great move Zion Ferrari yes
okay don't you want to like wouldn't
that cat like Hope Zion why we use named
after these i ah yes so is he RJ for all
is that what it is or what is he what's
his name we gotta wait and see what a
before we start I love RJ berry I am
very I am very high on RJ so steps for
kristaps Ferrara Wow Wow okay we're
gonna do that
yeah I thought this was we're gonna do
that
no Hey look the Celtics fan over there
isn't too happy anyway so not hurt all
right I'm gonna give you the floor man
what do you think here what do you think
because the Nets have now let's be
honest the Nets have now taken the buzz
the buzz is now in Brooklyn there's no
two ways about that in this town which
is where I've actually had people ask me
so are you a nets fan now Mike that's
not how sports works okay you don't
watch a team for most of your life and
then a new team comes along and they
have some some better talent and then
you go I'm gonna go be ID to me that's
not house really ask you I've been asked
well I guess maybe because I'm from
Brooklyn as well oh I see so because
nobody's asking Laker fans right now hey
you're gonna become well obviously they
have got LeBron and they have right then
he Davis right and I don't want to bring
up an I mean I don't bring up Anthony
Davis to you too but um so but I think
that's ludicrous
you're not giving up the nature she's
not gonna give up on the Knicks are you
no never but you know it didn't make me
think of an interesting question so if I
was growing up in Brooklyn when the
Dodgers were there I would have probably
loved the Dodge of course then they
moved to LA what do you do like I think
that's a much more interesting question
than like you're gonna like the team
that's now good that much what happens
if your team that you love moves away do
you stick with that team or do you
follow the new team that comes in well
the thing that you're kind of lucky
about obviously having a healthy kid and
having a kid is it makes you lucky on
the spot yes what what is his real name
Jacob Jacob Jacob so he said you're
lucky that Jacob is not like six seven
eight daddy take me to go see Durant and
Kyrie then because now you're now you're
punished for what because of what you
just said go back to sleep go to sleep
with no dinner you're not you give me
your phone cuz that's gonna be a lot of
the issues here in town um unless you
know look I'm sitting here saying Jacoby
Brissette is gonna still potentially
take the Colts to win I think they still
win the division in Indianapolis we have
no idea what Barrett's gonna look like
or any of these other kids that were
we're balling out so yes our league and
the coach I love the coach that's the
thing so for me the thing I am okay with
about being a Knicks fan now is and I've
said this it's been over a year now I
finally feel as though we are all in on
the plan whereas it used to be we're
gonna try to rebuild but still compete
and you you often wondered like are we
gonna like okay we got Derrick Rose and
Noah like are we rebuilding or are we
competing and how do you do both of
those at the same time it doesn't really
seem like something you could do this is
the first time at the Knicks where it's
like we're investing in young talent we
are not giving away future assets young
assets for maybe some veteran guys who
could maybe help more now we're just
investing on the youth and uh you got to
do it I'm in you got to do it the way
the Clippers did it exactly which is
which is draft smart get a bunch of
these players maybe if you do get
somebody that like a Lou Williams that
can drive on your lap you do hold on to
him and then when it's time for Yanis
just look to survey the scene in two
years you got a ready-made team where
he's like okay I can go there and win as
opposed to this time around where you're
just hoping Durant rice decides New
York's my home or New York's a place
that I want to go and Kyrie is gonna
come join me cuz he would grew up in New
Jersey right that's got it now this has
got to hurt you
this is this particular is gotta hurt
you cuz I brought this up as well okay
I'm ready for it
Kyrie saying he grew up a net fan like I
know that there's a picture of him
rooting for the nets when Byron Scott
was the coach Jason Kidd year you know
what I mean like that one nice to know
that when we were getting loved going
out to watch to watch genuine Martin and
the New Jersey he lost Tiree all those
great memories growing up and runnin or
an arena like I don't I never really
heard that one before but there he is
you know standing on the Brooklyn Bridge
talking about how this is kismet I was
sitting there like shaking my head on my
combo no but no there's like a
photograph of him I guess in a Nets
Jersey Jersey side or before he signed
now nobody was in a head like they honor
nobody Co but when no no
came out in his video standing on the
Brooklyn Bridge saying hey here I come
Brooklyn it would be nice if you were to
drop that image a little earlier but I
do think you can't take something from
the Brooklyn model of free agency which
is these elite players they they don't
want to just come to a team for it to be
their team you gotta have some players
or surround them and the Nets did I mean
I'm sure levert didn't her didn't woody
didn't hurt the coach didn't hurt so
there's right being good in young
infrastructure there so that's what I
think the Knicks are onto now okay and
now let's move to power before I let you
go season six this thing is uh winding
down and it's been a adjust talked about
it before but the radio artist is here a
heck of a run for you on the show what
has this been for you bud you know it
really actually got summed up for me a
week ago we had the premiere for season
six and this goes nicely with our
previous conversation on the next the
premiere for season six was at Madison
Square Garden it's great and my man 50
cent put on a great concert before they
showed the first episode there was
thirteen thousand people so watching it
in that environment it almost felt like
you're at a sporting event P characters
were coming on screen and the crowd was
getting up and cheering characters are
coming on screen the crowd was booing
it's like we're at a sports event here
so right I am I am extremely lucky power
has been an unbelievable follow up for
me to Entourage it's been maybe my best
role ever it's been some of the best
writing I've ever had to work with and
uh it's bittersweet because I I'm I'm
excited to see what's next but I'm very
very sad to kind of see it go you know
well you got your pod that you're doing
too right that's still doing the pod
your wife is producing it yeah I mean
we've slowed down in the last couple of
months with the the kid and all the
producing of Jacob's yeah we produced
the untitled BRE and Jerry project which
is our son right we figured out this
name but uh but yeah man life is good
that is great check out power on Sunday
nights and you're welcome anytime man
it's really good to see it I Love New
York rich I and I and I love LA Jerry
whenever you're out there I'll be back I
mean just just let me know you know when
you drop into town I'd love to have you
there and good luck to your g-men and to
uh to the pinstripers here to be
interesting an interesting October
September and October let's hope that is
for sure
for more of the
Kaizen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR Live or
download the Rich Eisen show app